dernier effet inattendu de l'ouverture
des pays de l'est ici au bourget
l'intention d'aeroflot deux roues
motorisés ces vieux lille où chine 86
pour les rendre moins gourmands en
carburant et donc économiquement
compétitif avec ceux des compagnies
étrangères
celui qui pourrait remporter ce marché
c'est le français snecma et son moteur
cfm56 5 s'est développée pour le futur
airbus européen à 340 l'économie en
carburant ainsi réalisé par aeroflot
pourrait atteindre près de 40 % et aussi
permettre aux iliouchine 86 se faire par
exemple moscou new york en vol direct
là où aujourd'hui les deux escales de
shannon et de vendeurs sont obligatoires
pour refaire le plein de carburant
même si ce premier contrat ne porterait
que sur la remotorisation de 25
appareils
c'est à terme l'ouverture du marché de
la plus grande compagnie aérienne du
monde et de celles utilisant des
appareils soviétique comme l'inde la
chine l'egypte ou la libye
quant à la monnaie d échange entre
snecma et aeroflot ce ne serait ni
roubles il dollars mais le titane un
métal produit par lui aussi en très
grosses quantités